it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you'll be visiting the
small open world of Campo mega in Metal
Gear Solid 5 ground zeroes coming out on
both current and last gen playstation
and xbox but some people are upset that
David Hayter is out in Jack Bauer to
display snakes back although he's
starting to look like a Silver Fox and
whether he's sneaking around planting c4
on trucks or silently knocking out
various soldiers and stealing their
weapons you can complete your operations
in a variety of ways making sure this
game has lots of replayability within
the missions save Chico March 18 this
week you get to travel back to spira in
one of the best JRPGs ever with Final
Fantasy 10 and 10 2 HD remaster with
each game taking about 40 to 50 hours to
be you'll have lots of time to enjoy the
stories battle sequences and the
unscalable cutscenes I know it's selfish
but this is my story swap out your
characters on the fly during battle or
change your outfit for new abilities
with extra content updated graphics and
improved audio you're not going to want
to take a pass on this and then start
playing blitzball March 18th also this
week you get to slap some ninja meet
around as the cyborg ninja hero Yaiba
and Ninja Gaiden Z enjoy techniques like
the vicious shoulder blade and the funny
pocket rocket to take down a
double-headed baby and dog from
half-life 2 yeah I'm noticing a pattern
this games been out in japan is march
six so it finally comes north america
and the 18th the final destination of
europe in march 21st take on the nuclear
izuna drop is tuesday and finally you're
a bloody bio terrace with some difficult
decisions and a loose beanie an infamous
second son but will you be a good Delson
or bad delsym either way your name is
Delson break out your chain march 21st
for further details visit gamespot's new
releases page release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
you